(en persan)
Mais la plupart de ces femmes
sont déjà rompues au combat.
composée de femmes, appartient
àbrbrbrbranche armée du Parti
de la liberté du Kurdistan,
le PAK, un parti d'opposition
c'est plutôt en Irak
qu'elles s'entraînent.
- (toutes): Ah!
- C'est aussi ici
le groupe État islamique
n n n n des forces de
la Coalition internationale.
parmi les combattantes.
Une qu'on ne peut
vous montrer pour
protéger sa famille.
se familiarise avec son arme.Ils
semaines, elle manifestait dans
les rues d'Iran, à Sananananana,
des amis tués par les forces
de répression du régime iranien.
des bâtons et les blessaient,
dit-elme une fois blessés,
ils continuaient de frapper,
alor
les atteindre pour empêcher
leeseseses révolutionnaires
de les emporter.
d'ambulance pour les blessés;
ils seraient allés directement
en prison ou dans les locauxenet
pour être torturés."
C'est pour lui éviter
le même sort que ses parents
Avec l'aide d'un réseau
clandestin de passeurs,
elle a traversé les montagnessss
qui séparent l'Iran et l'Irak
pour rejoindre les combattantest
de partir rejoindre les forces
armées kurdes, raconte Mafris,
que je serais en sécurité.
sécurité ici. J'apprends tout.
Ils m'oné é é é une arme
et m'ont m'enseigné
à tuer mon ennemi."
La vive colère de Mafris
est née avec la mort enn n n n .
Ici, Mahsa est connue
sous son prénom kurde, Zhina,
prénom qui n'est pas reconnu R ,
qui n'enregistre officiell
que les prénoms de langue perse.
Mafris veut aujourd'h
que la peur change de camp.
Plus jamais elle n
sans défense, dit-elle.
"Je suis furieuse contre
le régime
et je veux leur faire
ce qu'ils nous fon
les attaquer, les tuer pour
qu'ils sachent ce que ça f
Rezan a emprunté
le même parcours périlleux
depuis la région à majoritéququ.
"L'armée iranienne m'a
mes cheveux, raconte Rezan.
J'ai vu mes amis autour
L'Iran prétend que nous sommes
tous égaux dans la société;
ce s
L'Iran est la pire dictature
que vous ayez jamais vue."
Revenir en Iran,
elle en rêve, mais pas tant
qu'elle ne pourra pas faire fac.
"Pour chacune de
leurs balles, dit-elle,
Les innocents qui manifestent
ne peuvent pas se défendre,
sauf avec des pierres.
avec des pierres, soit
ils fuient le ré'I'I'I'Iran."
Au-delà d'un sentiment
ce que les jeunes femmestrtrtrtt
un sentiment d'appartenance,
appartenance àet à une histoire.
(chants)
Ils sont environ 10 millions.rt
le troisième groupe ethnique
en importance au pays.
Historiquement, la province
le Rojhalat, en kurde,
a to t t t tenu tête
au régime islamique de Téhéran.
Ces habitants subissenririririrs
depuis bien avant la révolution
islamique, et la répression
y a toujours été plus sévère.
(cacophonie)
Dès le début des manifestations
en Iradedededededededededededede
du Kurdistan iranien,
en est devenu l'épicentre.
Le Kurdistan Human Rights
basée à Paris, a pu confirmer
la mort de 54 Kurdes aux mains
des forces du régime iranien
depuis le début du soulèvement
nous avons été réprimés,
elelelelle, par le régime irani.
On ne peut pas parler ou étudier
dans notre langu l l l l l l l "
Avant dvevevever refuge auprès
d'elles, Rezan ignorait presque
tout des Peshmergas, du PAoioio.
"Chez moi, au Rojhalat,
dit-elle. Mais ici, j'ai appris
que nenenene terre, un pays
qui est occupé par un ennemi.
On ne nous permet
kurdes, là-bas; ils veulent
éliminer notre ident
Une identité qu'elle revendique
aujourd'hui et qu'elle veut
(slogan)
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
au Kurdistan irakie